when we talk about we talk about
approach trolley problem actually
research has been done on the kinds of
people who are willing to shove the fat
guy over the rails and what that
research has uncovered is that these
people tend to be utilitarians in our
society okay they tend to be people who
are able to get the job done who are
less morally squeamish now you know I've
actually presented a variation of this
dilemma to to to to various Psychopaths
I'll give you an example of what they
start what the variation of the dilemma
is imagine that you are a transplant
surgeon okay and you have five patients
all in need of a transplant
okay so heart lungs whatever whatever
okay and they're all going to die if
they don't get that transplant but there
are no matching donors available okay
just by chance a young traveler happens
to walk past your surgery one day for a
just a regular checkup and it turns out
hypothetically that he is a direct match
for all five okay now imagine that you
are the transplant surgeon imagine if
there was no come back to you if that
traveler somehow disappeared okay would
it be right to kill that young traveler
in order to take his five organs to
transplant them into your five patients
okay now okay
most people again it's the five on one
life scores exactly like the the trolley
problem but most people would say
absolutely not no you know that's that's
just not right it's ethically not right
to to to kill that person but I've given
this to psychopathic killers and they've
said well actually you know what imagine
if you were the families of those five
guys you know one one life lost is is
that really is it really that bad when
you're saving five others you know what
if that guy was an evil terrorist and
the five guys who needed the transplants
were peace workers or aid workers for
instance would that make it any
different now these are kinds of not
exactly that but these are kinds of
scenarios either
kinds of decisions that world leaders of
politicians have to grapple with I mean
here's another little one which had to
conjure with imagine that you were
hypothetically left in a room with a
newborn baby okay and he left in that
room for 10 minutes with that newborn
baby and I told you you have to believe
this is true that that newborn baby will
grow one day into a Dolf Hitler okay and
I told you that there would be no moral
comeback no legal comebacks on you were
you to kill that baby with a pillow and
walk out of that room now what would you
do would you kill that baby and save
millions of lives further on down the
line in history or would you not be able
to do it okay these are moral conundrums
which are kind of played out in everyday
life I'm obviously reducing these two
absurdities but these are kinds of the
kinds of decisions on a lesser level
that you have to make if you're uh if
you're a politician or if you're a world
leader sending anyone out into battle
knowing that there's a chance that they
might not come back
you know committing thousands of troops
to a war is something that you know not
many people can carry lightly on their
conscience and if you look at
psychopathic traits well actually you
know psychopathic traits are pretty well
pretty well represented in politicians
and world leaders you know you think
about it you know politicians have to
and leaders have to deal with with all
sorts of nasty kinds of crises during
the administration's anything from the
threats from rogue states to natural
disasters like hurricanes or floods also
though they have to be pretty confident
to run for office at all they have to be
very good at presenting themselves in a
certain light and they have to be very
persuasive or manipulative I mean one
senior UK politician who should offer
obvious reasons remain nameless had a
great quote and he said to me you know
in politics the only way to know who's
stabbing you in the back is to see their
reflection in the eyes of the person
stabbing you from the front I mean
that's a great kind of quote which for
me
comes up that kind of snakes and ladders
game every man for himself
cutthroat kind of existence that that
characterizes politics I would say
probably across the board in most
nations of